[Music]  well it's official Sally Field is an  excellent matchmaker nearly a month in  the making Sally's youngest son Sam  finally met his Olympic crush Adam  Rippon Sam in the US figure skater  crossed paths at the 2018 Human Rights  Campaign dinner in LA on Sunday where  Adam received the HRC visibility award  this feels right  the two cozied up for a couple selfies  Sam shared the pics with a simple  caption thanks mom the chance meeting  came a few weeks after Sam shared this  screenshot of his mom trying to hook him  up with Adam riding Sam he's insanely  pretty find a way well Sally took  matters into her own hands retweeting  the pose and tagging Adam clearly it  worked like a charm  so I actually reached out to her son and  I said you know what I really admire  that your mom just went there will  definitely be friends  [Music]